et
[Musique]
un enfant né dans la toundra et toujours
nomades par nature et son plus jeune âge
il sait que la vie est un mouvement
perpétuel neuf mois par an les petits ne
l'est sont à l'internât loin de leur
maison et tout ce qu'ils veulent c'est
rentrer à la maison dès qu'ils le
peuvent
certains sont si un patient qu'ils
n'attendent même pas les vacances et
s'enfuit dans la toundra
hé hé
lev 0 teto représente la troisième
génération d'une famille de neste
éleveurs de rennes
ils sont éleveurs de père en fils lui
aussi est allé au pensionnat puis il a
obtenu son diplôme de vétérinaire et
retourner chez son père dans la toundra
ici il s'est marié a maintenant trois
enfants depuis l'internât il emmène son
fils aîné d'ahn il et son neveu arthur
voir leur grand-père pour les courtes
vacances de printemps avant la journée
des éleveurs de rennes
le principal festival de l'année
oh
d'autres parents viennent aussi chercher
leurs enfants à l'école pour les ramener
à la maison pour les vacances
bonjour bonjour nous aimerions la
ramener à la maison pour les vacances
d'accord mais soyons de retour le 7
je voudrais parler à son père né à sa se
comporte mal et dit qu'il ne veut plus
revenir après les vacances
mais il faut qu'il revienne
les enfants de la toundra vont toujours
à l'internât chaque automne ils savent
qu'ils ne reverront pas de sitôt leurs
parents
le rédacteur en chef du journal le nord
rouge se dit aussi enfants de la toundra
voilà comment il traduit son nom est
nette
chef de la tribu des coquillages revenu
d'entre les morts
fils de musaraignes petit fils d'ours
polaires arrière-petit-fils de morse en
russe
oncle fiodor
il dit qu'il est revenu d'entre les
morts parce qu'à sa naissance dans une
tente de nomades
il était cliniquement mort son père
avait abandonné tout espoir
mais sa mère et sa grand-mère lui ont
sauvé la vie et l'ont élevé il s'est
empressé de les retrouver après s'est
enfui de l'internât quand j'étais à
l'école primaire en ce1 deux amis et moi
même nous sommes enfuis du pensionnat on
est allé dans la toundra toute la
journée et toute la nuit on a marché
vers ma tante
j'essayais tout le temps de les
encourager je leur disais tenez bon
voilà allez déjà là la tente on en voit
déjà le sommet son article s'intitule
pourquoi nos enfants meurent c'est une
histoire tragique des élèves qui
s'enfuit des écoles et prennent le
chemin de la toundra nous les avons
cherché si longtemps on a ratissé toute
la toundra ils sont morts près du
village mort de froid
bonjour leurs camarades de classe sont
jaloux parce qu'ils ne savent toujours
pas si leurs parents viendront aussi les
ramener à la maison les filles ont
toujours plein d'affaires c'est le
dernier cours avant les vacances
scolaires
aujourd'hui nous allons dessiner notre
tondra via aimé notre maison d'accord
m
pour arthur et dhani là cette image sur
la réalité sous peu
avant la fête des éleveurs de rennes ils
doivent rassembler le troupeau dispersé
de manière chaotique dans la toundra
cela semble impossible
mais peu à peu les enfants aident les
adultes à rassembler les animaux
sergei 0t tôt le chef de famille n'y
participent pas il observe tout ça de
loin comme un général supervise en son
armée son jeune fils et son neveu
s'inspire de lui il attrape des rennes
pour un attelage qui sera ensuite le
meneur du troupeau c'est la vie les
vieux rennes doivent céder leur place à
des animaux plus jeunes si un animal est
calme on le mettra avec des femelles
mais s'il est vif il peut faire de la
course je vais vérifier ça maintenant
au pensionnat les enfants reçoivent une
éducation de base on leur enseigne les
mêmes matières que dans les écoles
ordinaires comme les mathématiques la
physique ou la chimie
il existe également des disciplines
comme l'ethnographie et la culture au
logis afin qu'ils n'oublient pas la
toundra et leurs racines pour qu'ils
apprennent l'histoire de leur terre
natale
[Musique]
ses fils à pense rarement à la toundra
elles sont emmenés loin de leurs foyers
chaque année et se sont attachés aux
villes et villages où la vie est
beaucoup plus confortable
il n'y a pas de télé dans une tente
je ne sais pas je m'ennuie là bas il
faut travailler toute la journée
prendre soin des reines et préparer le
cuivre maxime reste hors du chemin
arrête de te balader issing trouve
quelque chose à faire annan rk guy
écrivaine et enseignante nenets reconnu
a créé son propre système d'éducation
alternative pour les enfants de la
toundra regardez c'est une communauté
résidentielle pour enfants c'est la
partie de la ville où ils vivent et
étudient et joue elle a dû attendre
longtemps pour que son projet se réalise
15 ans durant elle a vécu en nomade
prenant soin des reines elle sait qu'une
bonne éducation doit se baser sur le
travail quotidien qui est absolument
essentiel pour survivre dans le grand
nord
allez-y plus fort il y assez de travail
ici pour tout le monde
[Applaudissements]
dans notre constitution c'est écrit noir
sur blanc que les enfants des peuples
autochtones doivent recevoir une
éducation gratuite mais ça ne veut pas
dire que tout doit être offert à l'école
il ya toute une équipe qui s'occupe
d'eux des vigiles des femmes de ménage
qui lavent la vaisselle et nettoie tout
c'est à dire qu'on fait tout pour eux
donc quand ils font face à la vie réelle
ils n'ont aucune idée comment se
débrouiller il quitte l'école sans
expérience dans les internats les
enseignants observent un changement dans
l'attitude des enfants en 5e et 4e être
séparé de sa famille
ce n'est pas rien d'une certaine manière
un enfant se détache peu à peu de ses
racines
c'est une génération perdue quand il
aura terminé l'école il devra choisir
entre l'éducation supérieure et le
retour à la toundra que va-t-il choisir
il a été séparée de sa maison mais il
n'a pas eu assez de temps pour
s'enraciner ici non plus
les violonistes et nénette de l'école
d'art ont longtemps vécu en ville mais
elles n'ont jamais été séparés de leur
famille
une fausse note allez encore une fois
depuis le début de la mesure mais
n'accentue pas trop au milieu on y va 1
2 3 pour eux le mouvement perpétuel n'a
rien à voir avec la vie dans la toundra
c'est plutôt une célèbre composition
musicale de carl beau
dans la toundra il n'y a que des
moustiques nous vivons en ville et par
tous en vacances dans d'autres villes je
ne comprends pas comment les gens
peuvent-ils vivre
il y fait froid et tout est sale vous
devez vous réveiller tôt le matin tous
les jours pour chauffer votre maison
[Musique]
pas besoin d'aller dans la toundra pour
skier il y a beaucoup de neige en ville
pendant la majeure partie de l'année les
paysages urbains n'inspire pas sergei
c'est rod et au sa famille ne se sent
chez soi que dans la toundra
chaque printemps les hommes rénovent
leur parc de traîneau les femmes n'y
prennent pas part ce mode de vie est
resté inchangé depuis plus de 100 ans
la configuration des traîneaux
d'aujourd'hui reste la même
qu'auparavant sauf qu'ils sont
maintenant un peu plus petit je passe
parfois par le vieux cimetière où j'en
vois des normes
je pense que les gens étaient peut-être
plus grand à l'époque
[Musique]
ici dans la toundra anr cas guy a vécu
l'expérience la plus traumatisante de sa
vie quand sa fille unique est morte la
tragédie la changer elle a cessé de
vivre pour elle même est devenue la mère
adoptive de 25 orphelins elle les a pris
dans des orphelinats et a créé une
petite communauté qu'elle a appelée
terre d'espoir tout ce qu'elle sait sur
l'éducation des enfants dans la toundra
lui vient de la nature
la première chose que j'ai remarqué
c'est que le cercle est omniprésent dans
le paysage regarder ce petit lac héros
ce petit village d'enfants est aussi
construit un cercle en fait les nenets
n'aime pas les angles enfants
lorsqu'elle était à l'internât anne a
souvent été puni pour désobéissance
on la mettait au coin elle déteste les
coins depuis lors selon elle les écoles
pour enfants de familles nomades doivent
être situés près de leur route pour
éviter toute séparation prolongée
c'est une école semi mobiles offrant une
éducation primaire non seulement pour
les enfants adoptés
mais pour tous les enfants que les
parents amènent des villages voisins et
des campements nomades
alors les enfants
aujourd'hui nous allons apprendre à
dessiner un poisson d'abord un arc comme
ça puis un autre en dessous on y ajoute
la que la tête les yeux et les nageoires
les parents sont en mesure de ramener
leurs enfants à la maison quand ils le
souhaitent
l'expérience prouve que si vous voulez
juste apprendre aux enfants à lire et à
écrire
vous n'avez pas à les séparer de leur
foyer parce que cela peut être un trop
grand sacrifice
jeudi c'est comme ça pour tous les
peuples autochtones
pas seulement pour les nets les enfants
est également la possibilité de
poursuivre leurs études dans leur tente
de nomades et il ya même un professeur
particulier qui vient leur donner des
cours
dimitri korman suis encore des études
pour devenir enseignant mais il
travaille déjà
il enseigne la langue et la littérature
russe à ivan et galina une famille
d'éleveurs
il chasse qui a peint le lapin se cache
derrière un arbre près de l'arbre il y
avait un garçon et les chasseurs lui ont
demandé s'il avait vu avec de longues
oreilles oreilles je veux avoir mes
enfants près de moi je me sens plus en
sécurité comme ça comment pourrais-je
envoyé mon enfant à l'internât je n'en
dormirais plus la nuit
en plus de ces enseignants de terrain il
y a aussi des enseignants nomades qui en
plus de donner des cours se déplace dans
la toundra et s'occupe des serres la
communauté nomade dana a son propre
petit troupeau de 300 têtes ils ont peu
à peu rassemblé ces animaux avec l'aide
de plusieurs familles le berger ivan
n'est pas le seul à s'en occuper
les enseignants à nice grégory l'ap
thunder l'aide aussi ils iront bientôt
dans la toundra retrouver d'autres
éleveurs de rennes grégory n'est pas
seulement professeur de mathématiques il
apprend aussi aux enfants des
compétences pratiques dont chaque
nomades a besoin
dans la montagne le temps peut changer
en quelques minutes
ici au dessus du cercle polaire arctique
les conditions peuvent être extrême
vivre apprendre et bien sûr à coucher
tout cela peut être très dur nadal ya
fadeeva spécialiste en néonatalogie au
sein du service médical aérien a reçu un
appel d'urgence
une mère a besoin d'un traitement urgent
pour un accouchement prématuré
le message radio décrivait son état
comme critique à tout moment un bébé d'à
peine 500 grammes pourrait n'être
natalia est habitués à ces conditions
extrêmes et a même procédé à des
accouchements à bord de l'hélicoptère
elle sait qu'elle doit se rendre auprès
de ses patients
peu importe les conditions
météorologiques et où que ce soit dans
la toundra
elle est également très consciente que
ce travail peut également présenter de
sérieux risques
nous sommes habitués à ce genre de
situation peu importe que ce soit un
week end ou un jour férié
nous sommes toujours heureux quand ils
retournent dans la toundra en futurs
éleveurs de rennes
nous nous faisons du souci pour eux et
pour leurs familles nous voulons qu'ils
rentrent chez eux sains et saufs comment
tu t'appelles galina assieds toi là-bas
c'est son premier jour de vacances
n'oublie pas le reprendre tes affaires
pouvez vous m'aider à la soir bien sûr
anita
tout s'est bien passé la future mère a
été emmené à l'hôpital attend cet
hélicoptère effectué plusieurs missions
médicales d'affilée chaque jour ils
transportent les femmes enceintes à
l'hôpital pour leur suivi médical et
l'accouchement
une fois que les bébés sont nés et que
la mer est prête à quitter l'hôpital
ils retournent à leur tante de la même
manière qu'ils sont partis grâce au
service médical aérien
[Musique]
oui
la caravane de sarraute eto'o se déplace
d'un corps nomades vers un autre
ils doivent parcourir 150 km pour
arriver à la fête des éleveurs à temps
mais personne n'est à l'abri des
surprises
un faon s'étaient écartés du troupeau
fatigué effrayé il s'est détaché du
troupeau et c'est perdu
on ne peut pas arrêter tout le troupeau
pour l'attendre il se fait tard et les
nomades doivent encore planté leur tente
hommes femmes enfants tous ont leur rôle
à jouer
tout le monde connaît le sien il fait
presque noir au moment où ils en finisse
le matin malgré le vent sergei et son
petit fils partent à la recherche du
fonds sergei sort de la piste pour
chercher des traces fraîches mais une
telle recherche pourrait prendre trop de
temps
il décide donc de changer de tactique
enfin il retrouve le fuyard le fonds n'a
pas l'air du tout heureux de les
rencontrer
après avoir passé la nuit seul il a peur
de tout véritable chasseur n'est arthur
c'est qu'il est important de ne pas
effaroucher l'animal le grand père
regarde silencieusement sans un mot
lorsqu'arthur échoue mais il semble que
l'animal se moque délibérément du garçon
personne n'en sait n'y de telles choses
à l'école seule la patience et la
persévérance compte
maintenant il faudra apprivoiser le fond
quand il a faim il faut le nourrir à la
main après quelques semaines
il viendra de lui même demandé sa
nourriture salut yaakov voici les
coordonnées m 66° 11 minutes
le zoo technicien yaakov goody est
également originaire de la toundra et
bien rennes je vois laisser le montrer
le chemin il va nous guider jusqu'à la
vie il a déménagé au village après avoir
quitter l'internât et obtenu son diplôme
de l'institut agricole mais il a parfois
des regrets j'habite dans un village
j'ai un appartement mais de temps en
temps je me réveille le week end et je
n'ai aucune envie de rester entre quatre
murs si seulement j'avais ma propre cour
je pourrais faire quelque chose je suis
habitué à vivre dans la toundra à la
liberté et aux rênes je ne sais pas j'ai
été élevé dans cet environnement il
vient examiner les troupeaux et d'en
préserver la population
yakov connell fc rossetto depuis
longtemps et quand ils se trouvent dans
les environs
il passe le voir pour examiner les rênes
qu'il apprêtait la famille de son ami
c'est avec eux que yaakov a gagné les
courses de traîneaux lors de la fête des
éleveurs de rennes de l'année dernière
quand je reviens dans la toundra
je dois faire ça j'adore conduire un
traîneau
c'est comme une addiction
rien ne peux m'empêcher de le faire
salut comment savoir
je vais l'attraper belle prise
la famille de sergei c'est rod eto'o n'a
plus qu'une courte distance à parcourir
avant d'atteindre sa destination
la fête des éleveurs de rennes les
nenets n'ont pas besoin de montres il se
fie au soleil il se réveille au lever du
soleil à l'aube et retournent dans leur
tente pour se reposer quand le soleil
est couché
l'un des plus jeunes petits enfants de
sergei n'a que neuf mois du poisson
bouillie pour le dîner des plaques bière
au sucre et bien sur le plat principal
pour chaque nénette des tranches de
viande de renne cru congelés servie
froide
igor n'a que deux ans mais ses parents
n'ont pas de quoi s'inquiéter
il sait se nourrir parfaitement leur
fils devient rapidement assez autonome
[Rires]
[Musique]
le mode de vie de la famille de sergei
c'est rod eto'o n'a pas changé depuis 20
ans il a aujourd'hui douze petits
enfants
après avoir été père il est désormais
grand père aussi
ce film sur l'éleveur de rennes sergei
c'est rod eto'o a été tourné en 1993 je
viens de voir ma mère elle essayait
toujours de remettre de l'ordre
notre groupe était assez grand il
comptait environ 10 tentes et elle
disait calmement à tout le monde que peu
importe où on plante une tente nomade
il faut que tout soit propre dans le
campement j'étais dans l'armée quand ils
ont filmé cela en 1993 j'ai reconnu un
oncle avec cei
tantôt les cja ma grand-mère et ma mère
qui nourrissait le fond blanc
[Musique]
la famille de sergei c'est rod eto'o est
enfin arrivée au festival des éleveurs
il est arrivé en finale victoire il y a
toujours quelque chose à voir ici
dans ces compétitions nationales
seulement la crème de la crème peut
gagner chaque année il y à de nouveaux
concurrents et de nouveaux héros
le clou de la fête et la course de
traîneaux sergakis et rod eto'o et son
petit fils arthur sont venus encourager
l'ami de la famille yaakov srn aller
mais cette fois malheureusement pour lui
yakov a fini troisième
toute la famille se réunit pour les
vacances mais dans un appartement
ordinaire pas dans une tente
voilà valentina ma fille aînée la seo
les cias et rod et au hellas et salines
d'air mais c'est inné c'est ma plus
petit c'est mon trésor mon joyau le
sujet le plus important du moment
revient sur la table
doit-on séparer les enfants de la
famille l'éducation nomades at elle un
avenir après les vacances
ils devront renvoyer les enfants à
l'internât mon enfant va entrer bientôt
à la maternelle je me sens nerveuse est
vraiment inquiète
il n'ya pas de discipline dans cette
école nomade mais ici on a un emploi du
temps fixe réveillent petit déjeuner
déjeuner dîner et le coucher
pourquoi ne pas tout simplement
organiser votre propre école rassembler
tous les enfants dans une tente de temps
en temps elle rend ce n'est quelques
choses de manière informelle non je ne
veux pas que mes petits enfants soient
dehors où il fait froid je ne pourrais
pas envoyer mon enfant à l'école pour le
moment je veux dire si je vivais dans la
toundra
voilà comment coexistent deux points de
vue différents
deux opinions
un peu comme ce concours traditionnel
des nenets quelle attraction de bâton et
le lendemain tout reprendra sa place
sergei c'est rod eto'o et son fils lev
reviennent au campement et se dirigent
plus loin vers le nord seul désormais
car danila et arthur sont déjà de retour
à l'internât
e